[Music]  hello hi this is marlo yes  harper yes  come in  the  [Music]  excuse me mrs muller no  until you give your love  there's nothing more that we can do  happen from the garden  yeah it was delicious  mustn't do that  forbidden fruit oh god sorry i i'm  drinking  oh  you're tormented  it feels more like  wanted  yeah  something happened  my husband  went upstairs to our balcony  and let himself go  you must wonder why you drove him to it  right i didn't drive him to it  i could be true  but if you'd given him the chance to  apologize  he'd still be alive  what  a man  followed me out of the woods  he was stalking me what makes you say  that i saw him twice  twice  i don't know if he saw you once  [Music]  i'll play a game  you hide i'll see  [Music]  you must feel an awful sense  guilt  stay away from  me what are you  [Music]  [Music]  you